how many auditions have the most
auditions you've gone in on something
that you've got oh God first of all it's
been a long time since I've auditioned
and that's not a brag no it's no brag
you want to audition more [__] yeah but
now people don't even audition
put it on a zoom yeah everything is
virtual now and it really stinks we
talked about that only an hour ago at
lunch that I I miss auditioning I really
did it was because you felt like you had
accomplished something even if you
didn't get the part yes you showed up
you saw each other you saw the
competition you went in you had things
overcome because they were eating their
lunch or they were looking at something
else you had to get there you nailed it
you had to nail get you active and
involved in the whole process more
importantly you got to show your
personality yeah it doesn't come through
on a zoom that's right you're probably
trying too hard I don't know it's either
but when you go in there and you could
be charming and be yourself and you know
and take Direction well in those rare
occasions when maybe there was something
creative going on and I look I I did I
did a thing called um uh Murder in the
First which was Stephen bochko's last oh
yeah it was that the um no no no that
was uh was that Dylan Baker no ah no no
no it was a movie Murder in the First
yeah no that was dude that was Gary
Oldman yeah no and this this um
uh
uh this was Taye Diggs this was uh well
so a bunch of actors and I went in and
it was at the end of the day and I was
reading for the role that eventually
went to Tay Diggs and I really worked on
it really worked on it and I just know
it didn't it didn't work and bochko was
there you know Legend and he was
terribly kind and there were a couple
other casting people there
and I I left and I was really down on
myself it was the end of the day I don't
think I've been working that much and I
decided to turn around and knock on the
door no yeah
it was about six o'clock at night it was
winter in La so it was you know the only
thing to indicate that was that it was
darker a little earlier and they looked
at me they want to go home at this they
want to go home and they looked at me
and I and I must have had something in
my voice that said uh uh please let me
let me try this again please let me try
this again and uh I there was a moment
when bachco kind of looked around the
the question person that that answered
the door
and they said okay
okay and they gave me different sides
for a different character and I read it
and uh I got that role you know I know
that and it was it was it was um it was
wonderful on a lot of levels not only
getting the job but making that kind of
contact with somebody
who thought it was important enough to
actually have a physical
presence in this project and not just
kind of do it all virtually off a
computer off just that choice I mean I
love that that's Brave that I had a
similar story that was not that long ago
I wasn't working either this was
15 2015 and it was a new show called
Studio City it was a pilot and uh about
two sort of based on a true story uh
about a drug dealer and his daughter in
the valley in the 80s and uh that's a
good idea yeah and um because she's
saddled with Dad and now I I read this
pilot I thought this I I have to be
considered for this role and I called my
agents they called me back and they said
they don't see you in the part and I
said of course they don't see me in the
part I have to show them we had to beg
it was John Wells producing we had to
beg John Wells to go in
and I got it I got it wow and they got
this unknown to play my daughter her
name was Florence Pugh what and uh Fox
did not pick it up it's a great freaking
pilot you still have that pilot I don't
have a copy of it 2015.
um that is you know like I have a
similar story where I go you know what
let me read one more time she goes no I
think we got it I think you did a good
job I think we're good and I go yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
have you ever what's the biggest tank in
audition you ever had because I had one
where I went in I started I wasn't
prepared and I thought I could just do
it like a real good cold read and it was
somebody who cast me in a couple of
things and I I looked at him after the
second taken I go
I'm awful and you know it and I know ah
Rosie it's I go no no I'm gonna go home
I'm gonna leave I'm not gonna waste any
more of your time and uh I love you and
I left and I didn't even come back
that's a self-talk yeah I just I just
was like you know it was just you know
it's one of those things I didn't know I
thought I was not right for this there's
no way I'm getting this so I didn't
prepare and then I went in and looked
like an [__] have you done anything
like that well
for me I always I think I'm always
prepared because I'm too terrified not
to but the one that was just an obvious
one I went right after Will and Grace I
went into audition for Band of Brothers
I did too I met with Tom Hanks yeah and
I could just see in his eyes when I'd
finished
that there was no room at all for me and
I I found my agent for princess any
feedback and they said Tom thought there
was still a whole lot of will Truman
going on and he wasn't wrong I I took a
long time to get that out of my bones
but but yeah I would have had no idea in
2008 how to walk in and be you know a
young Soldier because you were wearing
camouflage culottes yeah but you know
what what's funny is I remember them
saying they don't want any uh known
actors that are trying to cast all on so
maybe that like that's what he was
saying I was already in my 40s by that
that's not what he was saying no he was
saying that yeah